Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is
two one nine two. David P. Here is a
voicemail caller who asks about something
that really opens up a major can of worms.
Major can of worms. Take a listen to this.
Hey, David, so I've been slowly getting
Speaker 2: more involved in the stock
market recently. I was wondering if
you had any recommendations as to who
Speaker 1: you might listen to for for advice for
that or if you have anyone yourself. Thanks. So,
listen, here's the deal. You don't need to listen
to anyone, you don't you don't need my advice on
this continues to be. Pay no attention to
stock pickers or market timers of any kind.
The advice is the financial advising industry is
99 percent based on making really simple. Things
appear to be complicated so that you pay someone
for advice. Is the stock market going up?
Keep buying index funds. Is the stock market
going down? Keep buying index funds. That's it.
That's the strategy. And then just wait, you've
got to filter out the noise. And we've recently
on live streams been doing kind of debunking of
so-called financial guru Dave Ramsay's financial
advice, which is often sort of like just right
wing Christianity based. It's not something I
like to get involved in myself. I've talked before
about the futility of picking individual stocks,
if you believe. That, you know, something no one
else does, and you can pick individual stocks and
know when to buy and when to sell. Allocate
some small amount of your assets to that,
and I consider it gambling. I own some
individual stocks. But the vast majority
should be in the lowest possible cost. Wide,
broad based index funds. And over time,
those tend to go up and you don't need to worry
about, oh, well, the market's down two percent.
Do I buy? You set up a schedule and that's it.
I buy once a month on the first of the month,
I buy twice a month, the first in the 15th. If
stocks are going down, if the market's going down,
you're getting a discount. Great, you
keep buying. If stocks are going up,
the stuff you've already bought becomes worth
more. And then in terms of who to follow, if
you believe that someone in particular has really
great stock picking skills, whether you like Dave
Ramsey or I doubt he gives individual stock advice
or like Jim Cramer or some newsletter or whatever,
devote some small portion of your assets.
But my advice is about who to get advice from
no. One. The strategy is by broad based
index funds and just keep buying. And next
month we're actually going to interview Nick
mid-July, who just put out a book about this
saying You got to filter out the noise. This
individual stock picking and people saying,
Get in now, get out now. It's a distraction.
We'll talk about that more next month. We have
a great bonus show for you today. McDonald's is
temporarily closing 850 restaurants in Russia,
and it led to massive lines outside of McDonald's
in Russia. We are going to talk about the increase
in the portion of Americans now living paycheck
to paycheck, partially because of inflation,
and we are also. This is good news. Congress
has passed a bill to bolster the Postal Service
without cutting back on delivery, which it
looked like they were going to be doing,
slowing down and cutting back on delivery.
So all good news and all of those stories
are on two days bonus show. You can sign up
at join Packman dot com. Remember that Alex
Jones has issued an anti-endorsement of the
bonus show. Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
it makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: The fact that he is so against
it should make you think, Damn, there's
probably something interesting happening on
that bonus show. Sign up at Join Pacman dot
com and we have just a couple of days left
if you would like to apply for content coaching.
If you are a content creator and you would like to
participate in free, this is free coaching. We're
going to pick four or five people. We've had about
100 apply so far. You can apply at David Pakman
dot com slash coaching. Don't email me about
the coaching due to emails will be ignored.
If you're interested, apply at David Pakman
Unidentified: dot com slash
coach. See you on the bonus.